you're multiplying these rational
expressions no rational just means like
ratio like it's a fraction and just like
you learned about fractions before what
you do is you multiply the numerators
together and then the denominators
together and then you reduce but there's
another technique you can do where you
reduce a numerator and denominator or on
the diagonals a numerator and
denominator as long as the factors are
the same you can cancel them out so I'll
show you how this works first step is to
factor as much as you can so the first
one you can see this first numerator we
can factor this 2x minus 4 times X plus
3 okay where's the denominator this is a
difference of two squares we can factor
this as X plus 5 times X minus 5 same
thing over here this denominator is a
difference of two squares that's X plus
3 X minus 3 and then the numerator
really all we can do here is factor out
the greatest common factor we can divide
these both by X and so we've got it
factored so again if you need help with
factoring check out that video I did
about all the different types of
factoring it's called learn how to
factor but now this is kind of the fun
part and so what you can do is you can
reduce top and bottom or on the
diagonals top and bottom so X plus 5 and
X plus 5 those are the same those cancel
we've got X plus 3 and X plus 3 those
are the same those cancel and that's
really all that we can do that's all the
same all the factors are the same in the
top and bottom so at this point we
multiply the numerators together but you
don't have to really fill it out usually
your teacher will just say leave it in
factored form so it's x times X minus 4
and then denominator we have X minus 5
times X minus 3 and that's our final
answer and we've got it okay so let's go
to another example number two now this
one we're actually dividing now you
probably remember when you worked with
fractions earlier in math the keep it
change it flip it
we have remembering how to divide and
what that means is you don't you keep
the first fraction the same you change
this to multiplication and you flip the
second fraction the other way to
students often times remember it is
dividing is like multiplying by the
reciprocal okay so either way keep it
change it flip it or multiply by the
reciprocal so you keep the first one the
same first step those two factor right
so I'm going to factor the numerator
that's X minus 7 X plus 2 right the
denominator we can factor out an axe as
the greatest common factor
I'm gonna change this to multiplication
I'm gonna put the 3x squared in the
numerator now okay so I'm flipping this
I'm gonna factor the denominator so the
denominator factors to let's see this
would be negative 3 positive 2 because
see negative 3x and positive 4x adds up
to the middle term which is 1x okay so
now all we have to do is reduce right so
we can see that we've got X plus 2 in
the numerator cancels with X plus 2 in
the denominator
this X here cancels with one of these
X's here so I'm just going to change
this to a 1 okay 3 X to the first and
that's really all we can do so now we're
going to write this out we've got 3x
times X minus 7 and again I'm just
leaving it in factored form and the
denominator I'm just multiplying across
X minus 4 times 2x minus 3 now I just
want to address a question I know some
students have in their mind right now
and that's that you know Mario how come
I can't just reduce this X with like
this X and that's that's a good question
now you can only do this
reducing when the factors are multiplied
together and you're canceling top and
bottom that's really like dividing
multiple and dividing are inverses of
each other here you can see like this is
3 times X but this is X minus 4 you know
here you're multiplying and here you're
dividing but you can see these are
really not multiplied together you know
if this was like 4 times X then we could
reduce top and bottom you know that the
two x's but here you can see they were
actually subtracting and you know
division and subtraction they're not
inverses of each other okay so that's
important to pay attention to so this is
our answer for number two number three
see if you can do this one we've got X
cubed minus 8 okay over X plus 1 times x
squared minus x over 4 x squared minus
16 this one is a difference of two cubes
so let's see if we can do that over here
this is going to be X minus 2 x squared
plus 2 X plus 4 okay and then let's see
this denominator we really can't factor
so that's just X plus 1 and then this
one we can factor out an X so that's
going to be x times X minus 1 and then
this one we can actually factor out a 4
first so if we factor out a 4 you can
see we have x squared minus 4 and then
this is really like a difference of two
squares
X plus
two X minus two and we bring down the
four so let's put all that over here in
the denominator X plus two X minus two
okay so that was the tough part really
so now this is the easy part and kind of
the fun part we can reduce top and
bottom so we've got X minus two cancels
with X minus two and what else do we
have anything else that's about it so
that's all we can really do so in this
case we just have x squared plus 2x plus
4 times X I'll put the X in front here
and then X minus one and then this is
all over 4 times X plus 1 and X plus 2
so this one really didn't reduce down
too much